Tulsi gabbard is leaving the Democratic  party she announced it in a conspiracy  Laden Maga Style video where she talks  about an elitist cabal anti-white racism  and wokeness if you can no longer  stomach the direction that the so-called  woke Democratic party ideologues are  taking our country  and I invite you to join me this  shouldn't surprise anybody it's sad that  it took some of my fellow people on the  left years to come to this realization  Tulsi was always this kind of  reactionary pseudo populist contrarian  that's what she continues to be she fits  right in with the Maga Republican party  her first act as now a non-democratic  independent is going to be to go and to  help a candidate in New Hampshire who  just so happens to be a republican what  a surprise